madame monsieur bonsoir le président
zaïrois mobutu actuellement en france a
annoncé cet après midi et qui mettait
fin aux fonctions de son ambassadeur à
paris qui au mois de novembre dernier
souvenez-vous avait tué accidentellement
deux enfants dans les rues de menton
l'immunité diplomatique est enlevée
rien ne s'oppose plus à son jugement par
un tribunal franz olivier théron
isabelle staes document confirme ce
choeur opus et moi je vous avais dit le
maréchal mobutu attendu à jean claude
guibal le maire de menton l' annonce
officielle de la démission de ramadani
bahia une démission qui signifie la
perte de son immunité diplomatique
plutôt que d'attendre une hypothétique
décision du parlement zaïrois mobutu en
accord avec l'ambassadeur lui-même et le
gouvernement français a préféré régler
le problème différemment ramazani baya
déchu de son immunité aurait déjà
demandé un visa pour venir en france
prochainement
je vous un lance en même temps encore
les c'est la fin d'un sommet l'
ambassadeur 120 en prenant cette
décision le maréchal mobutu s'oppose à
la vie du gouvernement et au parlement
zaïrois côté français en revanche le
maire de menton se félicite de la
décision incidente au bout tout appris
là une décision exceptionnelle et
courageuse
je crois pouvoir dire qu'il a prises en
liaison
direct avec le président n'aurait plus
eu de française et premier ministre avec
jacques chirac et agité les familles et
le comité de soutien n'auront donc plus
à manifester comme la semaine dernière
puisque la justice pourra être rendu
prochainement avec nous en direct d'ange